all right numbers up friends
hello
okay
um I know I'd spoken to 176 just 176 are
you in here
okay sorry 176.
um okay let us start with one seven four
before we move on to two two four
hello my name is Alex kratzke from
Austrian TV pulse four so at first I I
will ask the question English congrats
thank you very much for the success um
how important is this as a German
speaking
movie how important is it uh
for the German Film Community English
it's a very big question in terms of the
responsibility that this film has to
should or is supposed to carry I think
we're all
everything is a push and every film goes
to Khan and a German film goes to Khan
it's going to be a push a German films
at the Oscars it's going to be a push
for the other films let's just all
support each other I think and hopefully
I think we do have a little bit of a
inferiority complex as German Movie
Makers you know because we feel like a
smaller country as opposed to with less
stars with less visibility
uh as opposed to England or America and
so I hope this gives me and a few others
a bit of confidence to say let's just do
it let's just do our movies
um two questions you and your crew
you're all wearing the Ukrainian flag
why is that and second question why do
you think the academy embraced this film
so big time is thank you
so what so why do you think the academy
embraced
embrace the movie
um this is not the Ukrainian flag it's a
ribbon that we have from the UN Refugee
organization and it's just to support
refugees that are just or people that
are displaced they're more than ever and
the movie we made is also also caused a
lot of the space displacement German
history has uh
um uh caused a lot of displacement and I
think it's our responsibility especially
in Germany to help others that now use
seek Refuge also from the Ukraine uh
just to give back in terms of what was
given to us people also being embraced
in America that had to flee Germany in
in the second world war especially
and the economy has
I'm very I don't know why they've
embraced it but they have very big and
we are so so happy and proud and
thankful and grateful that they did
um I guess the film we tried to make a
film about our past about our
responsibility in Germany uh towards our
history towards and and and our agenda
or urge for us to talk about our guilt
and our shame that that we've brought uh
in uh or or the the terror that the two
Wars have caused in the world
and then suddenly it became also by the
time we had finished the film about our
present
uh
uh and and again new terrorists had
broken out which we never thought it
would again in Europe and I hope just
that the book especially you know if we
keep rereading it that it has a part in
that at some point we will stop making
the same mistakes again and again in the
future
all right thank you very much we have
220 followed by 211. hello this is right
here to your right and to the end here
hey
and my question is you know since uh you
were uh against you know Argentina 1985
does it feel like a World Cup soccer
game and I mean what does it feel to win
against Argentina
it feels better to win against Argentina
in the World Cup
which we don't usually you know
sometimes there are they're great
matches Argentina versus Germany it's
usually like a big match it's a very uh
physical match and I have so many
memories of watching these matches and
I'm so excited about watching these
matches and to be in a room with
Santiago and to watch this movie and to
talk about a movie it feels very it
doesn't feel as competitive I have to
say I'm much more much more in the in
the heat of it when I watch the football
game this feels more like you're
thinking about your movie and how does
it feel but I don't feel that especially
with these other filmmakers it was
always like a very
uh you know maybe it sounds corny but a
very brotherly feeling we were sitting
there and we knew we had all made our
movies we had done the best that we
could and in the end it's up to the gods
who gets this or not yeah and uh I know
just that Santiago Mitra I just adore
his film and
um and I'm looking forward to watching
the next match Argentina versus Germany
and I hope Germany wins that time thank
you congratulations
you very much we have two 11 followed by
last question one three three Germany
um foreign
[Music]
sorry sorry to interrupt you would you
mind repeating your questions oh yes of
course of course so uh can you please
put into words how it feels like to win
for Oscars tonight and how are you going
to party
um
can I answer in German yeah or in
English both both please okay good so it
feels I think it might feel incredible
but I don't quite know yet because I
haven't processed and it's it's a little
bit of a uh I'm I'm always a bit
with my emotional reactions so
I think it'll sink in tomorrow morning
because it was so overwhelming and in a
way I'm a little bit on autopilot yeah
but I know for sure that I'm gonna party
heavily tonight all night long I don't
want to go to bed and I want to and the
nice thing is that all of our friends
the entire crew is here and we can
celebrate together
[Music]
um
at the Vanity Fair party for example
you can try to get in now I can and did
you want to answer in German as well yes
I do
um
this is
filtering
all right and number one three three
hello my name is Michael from USC daily
Trojan I wanted to ask um in terms of
your film uh what was the main I guess
meaning that you wanted to bring to
Global audiences that American American
other American films like Saving Private
Ryan didn't or what did you want to
highlight from your particular film
I wanted to uh make it whenever I watch
America on British war films which are
usually done there I I absolutely love
them but I noticed that they're told
from a very different perspective and
that they're allowed to have a Winner's
perspective they're allowed to have a
sense of Pride and honor about what
America did in the world because they
liberated Europe from fascism in the
second world war in the first world war
they were roped into a war that they
were against
um and so and they just so have no
choice in a way and
um so logically those films must feel
very different they must have a very
different feeling and I thought it might
be interesting to show how German film
would look like that it can't have any
Heroes that any death that happens is
going to be another life lost and
there's no no there's no hero at the end
no one in a way no one can survive
because we all know what happened in
history and we imbue every every
decision in the movie with our sense of
responsibility and also guilt
and that makes just a very different
movie than an American or English movie
and I thought that's maybe worth sharing
wonderful thank you so much and
congratulations on your videos thank you
so much
[Applause]